foreign
Lansing Michigan to start off this hour
Hey Joe what's up
hey Dave it's honor to speak with you
you too how can we help
so I'm a little nervous to say this uh
to Dave Ramsey himself but I typically
use credit cards for all my day-to-day
transactions oh what I know I know I'm
actually wanting to switch over to cash
but every time I do switch to spending
with cash it seems like I actually spend
more even if I do stay within my budget
for example if I'm like at the grocery
store and I have say 50 left in my
budget towards the end of the month
um if I'm using cash and it's sitting
there in my envelope I'll go and grab a
couple steaks maybe a you know case of
beer or something whereas if I'm using a
credit card already knowing that I've
racked up 400 bucks on this month's
statement it really keeps me away from
you know spending that little extra
money and making that statement hurt
that much more when it comes in the mail
so my question is basically how can I
can I get over that mental hurdle and
switch to using cash so I don't have to
do business with people like visa and
MasterCard
okay well the um
the the principle of this whole thing
the old Grandma's old envelope system
and if you have a grocery envelope and
you have the money for your grocery
budget in the envelope you can't spend
that money on anything except groceries
and you can't spend uh you know it's all
and when it's empty you quit buying and
so your problem is you're ending up with
money left over which means you might be
over funding the envelope
okay you might be over you might be over
funding the category but the overall
idea behind the thing is and uh is that
we've figured out years ago at Ramsey
that personal finance is 80 Behavior
and so when we can do things that create
friction
that create mental and emotional
recognition of spending then it tends to
lower and control spending within a
category so for instance a more
sophisticated version of that is on a
website if you have to click too many
times and do too many Hoops to make make
the purchase people will bail on the
cart
yeah I've done that plenty of times jump
out because there's too much friction
the opposite end of that is Amazon Prime
you click buy now and it's on your porch
in an hour or two you know and so that's
the ultimate in low friction situation
but what we what the research tells us
and research done by MIT is that when
people spend cash it activates the pain
centers of their brain
when you spin plastic it does not
and I've heard you say that yeah but
it's not it's not working with you for
some reason I don't know what's wrong
with your brain but
right right so I don't care I don't care
what I would tell you to do if you want
to is uh switch to a debit card
not a credit card
and that's coming out of your checking
account and that way there's no chance
that you accidentally overspend a
category ended up in debt and then if
you want to do that that's fine uh years
ago I did that for instance with the gas
pump when I started teaching this you
still had to go inside the store to pay
for your gas
that I mean this 35 years ago right and
uh not and then they put those things at
the pump where you don't even have to
walk inside and you stick your card in
there and you know what's interesting is
the upheaval on high gas prices when you
had to walk in the store and pay cash
the political uh Firestorm was much
higher
because people noticed what they were
paying but when you don't even have to
walk inside and you just put your little
card in there and the only aggravation
is you see a large number but that's the
only thing then the political Firestorm
associated with high gas prices isn't as
high because they're really string the
president up the first time it went to
five dollars and we all paid cash now
it's just kind of like yeah well it's
one of those things and so uh but that's
what's going on so I would use your
debit card Christine you got a
suggestion yeah I'm curious you said the
you'll walk into the grocery store
sometimes with fifty dollars and then go
get some steaks in a case of beer that
sounds like more than fifty dollars have
you had the experience yeah what kind of
cheap steak are you eating
well have you had the experience when
you get to check out and it's more than
the 50 or what's kind of been your
parameters
I I more meant one or the other not both
at the same time yeah that put me over
fifty dollars
my default setting is very frugal I'm
I'm well under my means as is I maybe
I'm just you know getting too nitpicky
about it but yeah
um no I think I think you know what a
master is is you don't get
um
uh you you very seldom were overspending
before you met us
right
and so all we're doing is giving you
some guidelines and some mechanical
processes so yeah what baby step are you
in right now
um I guess technically I'm in six but
I'm doing more than the 15 in my
retirement that's awesome yeah very good
it doesn't feel like I'm in six yet I
still feel like I'm a young and you know
what you need to buy more stuff you're
too cheap
you need to enjoy some of your money
really I mean I don't have any to enjoy
still I mean I know I'm thinking you
know well you had some left over and
didn't want to buy a steak I mean so I
want you to enjoy some of your money a
little bit at the grocery store that's
okay you don't have to be on beans and
rice at this stage and so here's the
thing a lot of people most people that
we deal with are Spenders in our culture
but occasionally run into a Frugal
person like you and we all have to learn
all three
we have to develop all three money
muscles the generosity muscle the saving
investing muscle and the spending muscle
and the spending muscle means wise
spending but doing some we have to enjoy
money we have to save and invest it we
have to be generous if you're not doing
and frugal people tend to leave that one
off and Spenders tend to not do either
one of the other ones because they just
spend it all on themselves but um but
that that's what we run into right I
don't think that he expected such an
affirming response after calling it
about credit cards
well there is that but yeah yeah I would
chop up the credit card for sure and get
a debit card that's not a question
um and you know we're
anti-credit card here there's just so
many things that can go wrong with the
use of a credit card and the debit card
will do everything the credit card will
do has the same fraud protections I
travel all over the world my debit cards
I don't have any issues with them that
are any of you don't have with your
credit card all of us get the fraud
alert you know sometimes and no no no no
no no you know and all this did you buy
through three dollars worth of gas in
Canada nope I didn't um so something
wrong there that we all get those things
right but uh but but you know so I carry
debit cards that's all I carry our
company has debit cards hundreds of them
with our you know our team that travels
and everything else and so uh and they
use cash as well uh we don't have a
company credit card at Ramsey none of us
do and we don't even have and I
certainly don't have any at home
although Christine a full disclosure
after 30 years of doing this I'm still
trying to get Sharon to call it a debit
card what did she call it she still says
hand me the credit card after 35 years
of me telling people not to use a credit
card my own wife is a Trader no I'm
kidding now she actually knows what it
is but she just forgets she's like give
me the credit card and I'm like no don't
say that out loud somebody will hear you
you're sharing freaking Ramsay that'll
you'll start a rumor